que voler dans ce qu'il convient
d'appeler ''l'affaire griveaux c'est la
responsabilité d'internet dans la
publication de cette vidéo à caractère
sexuel faut-il changer la loi faut-il la
durcir il faut commencer par rappeler
qu' il existe des punitions forte pour
publication de vidéos sexuellement
explicites c'est puni de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 60000 euros d'amendé
le fait de transmettre ou diffusé sans
le consentement de celle-ci l'image ou
la voix d'une personne quand
l'enregistrement l'image ou la vidéo
sont-ce expulsé que sexuellement pardon
explicite faut-il aller plus loin et
jenny bastié je crois pas du tout je
crois que ça complètement démagogique de
la part des députés en marche d'abord
accusé tantôt l'un tantôt les réseaux
sociaux tantôt l'anonymat sur ces
réseaux sociaux ça n'a rien à voir
puisque dans ce cas précis on sait
précisément qui a diffusé ces vidéos là
l'artiste pseudo artistes russes tant
question pilote paul ince qui a signé
son méfait
il a été retrouvé et c'est donc je crois
que c'est vraiment un faux débat
ce n'est pas du tout la question de
l'anonymat qu' et qui est en cause
les réseaux sociaux font beaucoup de
dégâts je pense qu'ils en font beaucoup
en termes d'influencé des votes
notamment ce qu'on appelle les bulles de
filtres c'est à dire le fait qu' ils
produisent delà de la polarisation
politique très forte c'est à dire en
confortant les gens dans leur opinion en
leur donnant à manger de l'information
qu'ils recherchent déjà sans les
confronter à des points de vue adverse
et c'est ça c'est un vrai problème est
qu'il faut évidemment réguler
aujourd'hui vous avez un candidat
démocrate aux états unis bloomberg qui
utilisent les réseaux sociaux à foison
parce qu'il a énormément d'argent pour
créer de toutes pièces et une
candidature et ça marche un petit peu
quand même parce que justement il n'y a
rien derrière à part de l'argent et des
réseaux sociaux et des réseaux sociaux
et des réseaux sociaux
ça c'est un vrai problème comment
réguler ça en moins ce problème en
france mais je crois que c'est là on
pose vraiment le débat ce n'est pas la
question la question c'est
individus malhonnêtes qui diffuse une
vidéo qui d'ailleurs va être poursuivi
et peut être probablement condamné pour
cela
donc je ne vois pas l'opportunité de
créer une nouvelle loi il n'a
suffisamment déjà la loi via sur la
haine sur internet est une loi
liberticide qui va déjà encadré très
fortement ce qui se dit sur internet et
qui délègue d'ailleurs son contrôle au
houga phase qui est un problème
donc moi je trouve que c'est un non
débat jean louis bourlanges internet
avant d'ogeu suis sûr la loi via j'étais
je me suis abstenu parce que j'étais
très embarrassée parce que je vois je
crois à la nécessité de faire quelque
chose mais je crois aussi que la
possibilité donnée aux gars femmes par
exemple de faire eux-mêmes la sélection
peut-être idéologiquement et extrêmement
extrêmement pervers donc gg pas je ne
vois pas la vraie solution mais je suis
d'accord avec ce que du génie en
l'occurrence ça n'est pas ça du tout le
problème posé
c'est à qui appartient la corogne parce
que c'est ccc benjamin clée vous qui a
envoyé comme c'est comme s'il avait
envoyé une lettre avec une image il a
envoyé que c'est c'est une
correspondance l'image animée
c'est une correspondance alors on dit
toujours que qu'une être appartient à
celui qui la reçoit
en tout cas dans ce domaine là c'est
certainement pas satisfaisant mais là en
l'occurrence c'est la partenaire qui
semble-t-il lalala communiqué est-ce que
comment faut-il gérer cette affaire là
c'est c'est très difficile
en tout cas il faut faire attention ses
partenaires bernard de la villardière
on va dire c'est la faute à pas de
chance entre guillemets pour benjamin
griveaux c'est de dire qu'on ne peut pas
encadrer complètement et éviter ce genre
de mésaventure
oui c'est certain mais enfin ça démontre
en 20 ans sa très grande puis really tc
grande fragilité c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a vécu la sphère strauss
kahn de très près puis s'il était juste
trop scania donc voilà
n'a pas volé son prénom est comme une
très grande prudence
c'était moi je suis pas pour
effectivement alourdir la loi telle
qu'elle est prévue là aujourd'hui en mai
je suis pour la levée de l'anonymat sur
les réseaux sociaux ça c'est certain
parce que on est poursuivi pour injures
dès lors que c'est imprimé sur du papier
pourquoi on ne serait pas concept en
numérique aux pages et charles faute
mais il faut encore retrouver l'identité
de la personne qui vous condamne à mort
qui vous insultent ou qui vous traîne
dans la boue et moi je serais pour la
levée de total de l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ça me semble
évident normal il faut que les gars ça
joue le jeu évidemment mais il faut
aussi que les députées françaises soient
un peu courageux vous même vous avez
reçu des menaces explicites à la suite
de reportages vous avez pu faire
notamment sur les sur les banlieues sur
le communautarisme
vous avez demandé que soit levé
l'anonymat de retrouver les gens qui
vous menace et où s'étaient même pas
possible donc vous n'avez pas essayé non
je paye c'est non non j'ai pas essayé
j'ai pas essayé
c'est vrai que j'ai pas essayé par
contre j'ai été poursuivi oui devant les
tribunaux puis leur foi par marcel
campion avec le salon ce n'était pas la
station marcel coffy par le fort à
parise et puis parler et puis par l'ex
udf rassemblement des musulmans de
france et l'audience j'ai été condamnée
pendant deux ans et demi
mise en examen pour diffamation et à
deux jours de l'audience l'ex-udf a
retiré sa plainte
et figurez vous que j'ai voulu les
poursuivre pour procédure abusive parce
que pendant deux ans et demi on n'a pas
pu rediffusé le reportage j'ai été
condamné par un oui j'ai été mise en
examen en tout cas pour diffamation ce
qui n'est pas toujours très agréables
sur ces sujets là du coup j'étais un peu
exposé c'était compliqué pour moi de
voilà de prendre position et de faire
des reportages sur ce sujet d'ailleurs
la chaîne m6 m'a cité à la prudence
aussi parce que j'avais été condamné à
mort par j'étais sur une liste rhône
ardèche à une époque
et voilà est justement cette procédure
abusive l ap ap au but sûr parce que les
magistrats m'ont dit ah ben non mais
finalement il n'y a pas eu d'audience
donc il n'ya pas de délivrer alors ce
qui est vrai que c'est quelle dame le
pion la vraie vie et pas dans le pas
dans ce registre on appelle le djihad
judiciaire
sherbrooke il faut changer quelque chose
à la à la loi ou c'est vrai que je suis
sur le même registre que ce qu'a évoqué
au génie m'assieds que serrar noter le
partage
je crois le même âge y en a mais tout à
fait solidaire mais sur la sur l'animal
le racontons là on a un sujet qui est je
pense que si la loi elles d'après moi
c'est suffit et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en europe on a
des dispositions législatives qui sont
assez proches avec les deux ans
d'emprisonnement avec des amendes qui
vont peut-être pas jusqu'à 60 mille
euros mais qui sont un petit peu quand
même
dans cet étiage là on s'aperçoit quand
même que il faut aller ailleurs regardez
en angleterre depuis 2015 il existe un
dispositif est pourtant à environ 8% des
personnes se déclarent aujourd'hui sous
la menace de ce type de diffusion sert
de vidéos à caractère sexuel qui ne sont
pas consentis et qui ne sont même pas
autorisé de quelques manières que ce
soit par par les personnes et en plus
aujourd'hui la loi condamne la diffusion
qu'il y ait consentement puisqu'il peut
y avoir eu consentement quand on a
transmis les images et pas au moment où
elle est diffusée quelques temps plus
tard puisqu'on est dans la revanche la
revanche à caractère pornographique etc
mais ce que je veux dire c'est quoi
c'est qu'à côté ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut rien faire notamment sur toute la
partie qui est de mieux connaître mieux
maîtriser ce que sont les réseaux les
usages des réseaux etc
je pense qu'il ya à la fois en matière
d'éducation qu'elle soit d'ailleurs il
ciel ou continue quelque chose à faire
qu'il faut prévenir de ce que l'on peut
faire on pas pour protéger son intimité
avec les réseaux sociaux parce que ça va
très vite de partager des choses ça va
très vite de diffuser des choses quand
on est quelqu'un comme benjamin griveaux
on est censé avoir la distance
nécessaire il ya aussi tout ce qui se
passe avec des plus jeunes avec des
adolescents qui en gros c'est change
aussi ça c'est un moyen de chantage
c'est pas rien et je pense que tout ça
il ya à prévenir il ya à mettre un peu
en un filtre entre eux c'est quoi un
réseau social c'est quoi l'intimité et
comment on protège et comment on se
protège alors qu'il n'y ait pas cette
espèce de boule de neige sur la vie
privée
sage obtention les ados c'est très
impressionnant les prises à parti d'ado
etc
on pense évidemment à la ferme ou là à
la flamme il a c'est tout à fait et puis
il ya quand même quelque chose de
dérisoire dans la condamnation dans la
procédure judiciaire à la condamnation
et la manifestation même de la chose
grivot il peut avoir condamné tout le
monde sa carrière politique est cassée
n'est tout simplement parce que c'est
publié c'est tout donc il ya au cas
aucune façon de réparer il en aurait dû
quitter la campagne il n'aurait pas dû
partir parce que du coup il restera dans
l'histoire comme l'homme qui voit là
alors que s'il avait été élu ou pas sûr
que ses amis de rem est tellement désiré
qui continue je comprends qu'il ait
quitté parce que je suis pareil qu'il
était menacé qu'on diffuse d'autres
vidéos alors que soient les raisons pour
lesquelles il aurait abandonné à c'est
un écran plus sa famille non mais je
pense que je pense qu'il est illusoire
en tout cas de vouloir répondre par la
loi de manière juridique un problème qui
est quasiment anthropologique et
civilisationnel des réseaux sociaux une
désintermédiation généralisée le fait
qu'on ait accès direct désormais que
n'importe quel acteur citoyen puisse
interdit fusion d'informations sur
l'autre donc c'est une surveillance qui
n'est plus de l'état vers les individus
mais une surveillance mutuelle des
individus et rajouter la surveillance et
un surveillant je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une bonne solution et des raisons
c'est l'éducation qui permettra de
de lutter mais même éducation médias et
l'éducation des médias des
responsabilités du journaliste et
d'ailleurs vous renvoyer un article de
jean pierre le goff que j'avais publié
dans les pages du figaro qui est
excellent et kylie qui se pose avec les
changements de cette violence
intrinsèque de notre société qui a
conduit à ces voix là et je vais je
crois qu'on sera déjà mais on peut
parler d'éducation il faut le faire la
cetera mais qui me chagrine chacun à son
niveau doit sans cesse et chez jeu sera
que les médias comme une responsabilité
s'ils ne sont aussi de responsabilités
individuelles dans les collèges à temps
regardez regardez ce qui arrive vous
êtes responsable enfin faites attention
parce que les cocistes vous avez
peut-être des droits à la vie privée
mais l'écosystème dans lequel vous vivez
nous vivons ne prendre ne garantit plus
à livrer la vie privée n'existe plus au
21e siècle il faut se rendre compte il
faut agir malheureusement en conséquence
et les internautes qu'en pense-t-il en
ballon va le voir ensemble c'est assez
partagés faut-il des lois plus strictes
c'est oui à 57 % et non à 43%
voilà on rappelle que ce n'est pas un
sondage mais le point de vue des gens
qui ont la gentillesse et j'espère
l'intérêt de nous écouter ce sera oui
voilà il était le premier le port de
l'amateur il ya certains sites qui vont
couler un adolescent il faut quand même
se rappeler la fontaine à cet âge et
sans pitié
on laisse les animaux à christine quand
on est un homme public il faut être
responsable dit elle avec tous les
points d'exclamation qui s'impose à ses
yeux